leandro in the arianes is very close
just like me
clearly he's just trying to get back at
me for having landro here
y'all this is getting real petty
benyam invited his ex-girlfriend to
dinner without telling ari this is the
same ex-girlfriend who's behind he was
drumming on last season
she's gorgeous
i agree leandro we could look at her all
day
but
why is she there benyam seems more
worried about getting revenge than
keeping his fiance right now did he
cheat on you little did he know though
playing tit for tat would cause him to
end up in the hot seat plus ace
evelyn confessed that she and corey got
married a year ago
although she's been making it seem as if
they're not married yet trying this
dress makes the scene all
extra real i'm like oh my god oh my god
oh my god this is happening what am i
going to do girl
it already happened oh yes basically
she's been fooling her family the
producers and us
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia oh i
cannot wait to see how y'all feel about
binyam inviting his ex-girlfriend to
dinner
but before we get into that
benyum choked ari's ex-husband leandro
out
while they were boxing at the gym
okay
no he's not okay leandro tried to play
it cool that was intense but part of him
was like what the hell was that that
coming off guard completely benjamin is
not playing about leandro being a threat
to his family i want to talk like a mean
to me after claiming his dominance he
cut straight to the chase why you came
like here in italy she asked me almost
begged me to come because she was
feeling homesick
a little bit lonely so
i wanted to see what was going on why
she felt like that binyam also asked if
he had already slept together when she
visited the u.s and leandro stayed with
her i'm asking he's here
did you did you guess me like you know
just like
well men to me and just someone please
no just someone else
don't worry
you don't have anything to worry about
when he says i don't do selecting the
sex with early i don't know why he's
like when he talks
he's nervous like when i see him he's
nervous i don't trust him of course he's
nervous binium you just had your arm
wrapped around his neck now i know a
number of you might disagree with what
i'm about to say i already had a back
and forth with my friend about this but
after the fight
i started to feel bad for leandro i did
yes he crossed the line by coming to
ethiopia in the first place though he
was kind of asking for trouble but he's
going through all of this because he
genuinely cares about ari
i just care about ari and i want to see
how she's doing how she's doing with you
and you can tell it's beyond romantic
feeling he's my best friend also in my
opinion if binyam was truly handling his
business aka not staying out all night
when vinnie he goes out and stays out
all night you know and i would be alone
with the baby it's very hard yeah she
wouldn't have been begging leandro to
come in the first place so who are you
texting baby moving on as ari benny and
leandro were heading to dinner binyam
revealed that he invited his ex why
because
uh she's around here because i like to
just
invite her like something just looking
good together so fun fun
bennio clearly he's just trying to get
back at me for having landro here i get
that he wants to give ari a taste of her
own medicine but this
isn't the most mature way to go about it
and i know some of you are probably
saying well ari started it i agree but
to put out a fire do you add gasoline on
it
[Applause]
nice well it was burning all right bam's
ex zeon came in hot leandro in the
arianes is very close just like me
when i saw zion first walking
she's gorgeous she's extremely beautiful
to me it doesn't make much sense why
they are not together i would like to
know why
they ended up the relationship
now this is what binyam didn't think
about inviting his ex to dinner created
the perfect opportunity for ari to ask
questions i'd like to ask you like why
did you break up why did the two of you
break up questions that she should have
had answers to a long time ago why are
you asking her no you can ask him
anything you want he give you advice
it's only fair sorry he he asked me the
same question so yeah
it's fair you should answer the question
so i can't for me just someone says if
it's okay for you stop interrupting in
transit when she said translate i said
no
binium you better repeat every word
verbatim
she tell me yeah look at leandro helping
out did he cheat on you
[Music]
tell the truth
i think
you think
how do you know
come
she's never spoken to him about it so
just like ari and leandro didn't really
have closure from their relationship as
we saw last week
benyam and zeon haven't either
i don't get how you're still friends
with your ex but you don't talk about
why you broke up
you can see his reaction
zion revealed that she thinks bingham
cheated on her when he met his first
wife who was also american
but after she told her side of the story
about how it all went down as expected
benim translated it differently
when she sees like uh my ex-wife she
asked me who is she i tell her just i'm
doing custom for movies you're so
bullied oh this guy is so funny wow
oh my god okay is it just me or is that
not funny if you cheat it just own up to
it at least try to make us think you
changed your ways
zeon revealed that she never thought she
and binium would break up and because
she was so in love she didn't want to
believe he was cheating on her
well
[Music]
wait are they giving each other the eye
what was that anika
binyam claims he didn't cheat on zeon he
said he met his ex-wife after they
separated and then went on to say that
zeon is extremely jealous and got upset
that he moved on so quickly
that's that typical i don't wanna own my
part in an answer yeah blame the woman
for being jealous that you moved on too
quickly after she accuses you of
cheating on her
okay
everything is my fault and my family is
awful and nothing at all is your fault i
mean you're with him you know all night
when you guys are dancing whatever at
the club do you think i have anything to
worry about
why are you why are you wearing them i
don't know i mean
okay
right but you can love someone and they
can disappoint you she's like true
very true
and then she tried not to laugh when ari
asked her that
you know what i'm not gonna say much
else because the reality of it is is
that it's really none of my business i
just hope that this isn't one of those
situations where the pot is calling the
kettle black and what i mean by that is
i hope binyam isn't accusing ari of
crossing the line with leandro because
he's crossed the line while he's out and
about and not at home i've always
worried that he could make a stupid
mistake that might compromise our
relationship and this only makes my
fears worse key takeaway here know why
your partner's previous relationship
didn't work out before you get into a
relationship with them
it will tell you a lot
[Music]
all right
let's quickly touch on evelyn and corey
i invited my sisters over today so they
can help me with the planning of the
wedding what are you guys looking at
over there
wedding dresses so they've been planning
their wedding in ecuador and evelyn
wants to go with this wedding planner
that is quoting the wedding to cost
anywhere between 26 to 50 000
and cory
cory said nah that is too much i thought
perfect timing now while it's
understandable that he wants to save
money what he does next is extreme i
really hope that everyone's gonna like
it as evelyn was looking at wedding
dresses with her sisters corey goes and
pulls out the dress he thinks she should
wear look
it's got look open back
and it's got the slits on the side
it's a sister's prom dress
and it has a hole in it it makes a
really
horrible all dirty
is that dress
hole can you please just try it on i
think it will look nice it is
embarrassing to
have my sister's presence this
thing that corey did it's like oh look
at my
super cheap future husband right here
bringing me his sister's old dress for
me to wear it you heard her say future
husband right well there's no future
there because he already is her husband
while she was dress shopping with her
sisters who despised corey by the way
evelyn revealed that she and corey went
ahead and got married a year ago
korean
so basically she's been putting on an
act for her family and for the cameras
i can't wait to hear her explanation
because this
is pretty bizarre
all right well next week are you sure
this is what you want to do for your
future marrying beanie leandro gets real
with ari and ari clashes with binium
sisters once again
we hear about what happened in new
jersey you stayed with her while she's
pregnant and she lied about that
he's my best friend you know i sometimes
honestly i feel lonely because you don't
trust me
honestly i don't even want to talk
anymore so
am i leaving alone am i going
to leave with him
that's always so awkward when you get up
and no one else gets up with you
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]
you